histoire que vous allez découvrir est
basé sur des faits réels et s'est
déroulée en 2018 dans les grandes
enquêtes criminelles beaucoup de moutons
il ya des dossiers qui peuvent vous
sucer de la rd817 ainsi de diamant
nous sommes le fils du gouverneur vient
d'être retrouvé mort j'ai besoin de vous
mariah carey ou george bush george bush
un seuil que c'est une expression
française qui sont les nouveaux
collective moteur de mails où c'est dur
c'est valin et à vichy mangent les pieds
les mormons les coûts si tu te tuera la
safa c'est normal de rêver devant jupe
murdoch moi j'ai rêvé de cox et vous
étiez une poupée gonflable ils arrêtent
et pratt se tripoter ok alors c'est qui
douleur c'est qu'ils arrivent
[Applaudissements]
j'avais déjà promené toulouse devant un
bus rempli d'indian ont crié ta gueule
il y a des dossiers qui peuvent vous
sucer de l'intérieur
tel un aspirateur fou contrôlé à
distance par les forces du mal devons
penser comme le tueur se mettre dans sa
tête je perdais tout l'histoire que je
m'apprête à vous raconter la plus
extraordinaire la plus incroyable depuis
pirates des caraïbes
cette histoire est arrivé à deux agents
du fbi est devenu célèbre avec la sphère
pamela rose
les chars venus et douglas people
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour